you doing all of this
vice this is me man they still at lunch
yeah they fired
what up this is two chains and these are
my essentials
[Music]
this is rolling paper it's awkward
because this is the first thing he
brought out but
this is one of the first things i do
when i get up it is
organic whatever that means it's just
like a word that makes us buy stuff
right
i have a rapport with josh the guy that
owns this place so he keeps me lace
it's made in spain the birthplace of
rolling papers
i don't smoke plants or anything it
messes with my singing a little bit
it's a custom-made goyard fabric lighter
has my
logo on it tru the real you
a friend gifted it to me and it's
functionable
and it's flammable so kids don't try
this at home
i have a couple of go yard things i have
some travel bags some belts i have a
cou yard wallet the stuff in here i have
in here is basically a lot of
trappies paperwork my dog he has to
travel with me a lot
even my dog got id i'm saying like my
dog has sky miles you know what i'm
saying
like stop playing with me that's old
oh 2016. they're just so cute on there
my kids and everybody else got dogs this
my dog
like my homie these are called
lifesavers that's right airpods i love
them
for the same reason that you love them
for
you know you love something because as
soon as you think you lost them the
whole world has to stop until you find
these again so i've lost
a couple of times but i've found them a
couple times so we're even
what are you listening to now i'm
listening to my album rapper go to the
league i just got all the mixes and
mastering back
so i'm listening to the arrangement and
i'm very satisfied with what i'm hearing
yeah this is very essential for two
chains
up next is my phone kids
broke-ass people at home like to talk
about me not being up to date with my
thumbs
one i don't give a [ __ ] two i have
enough money to buy
ten iphone tens at any given time this
is i think a eight
works great has my kids on it i like the
face time too i like to see my kids and
my wife and my mom i like the face time
if a lot of my friends if they don't
have an iphone i'll buy one
just so i can facetime how many how many
months i don't need to tell people on
here
what's this it's ten thousand dollars
[ __ ] i don't know what that's that's a
yes
essential i've been waiting on this this
is called lip therapy
it's vaseline i smoke obviously so i
can't be having like big crusty lips
and even if i didn't win new york right
now and i'm sure a lot of people need
some type of lip therapies very cold
outside
so a lot of people like carmax and stuff
i think i choose vaseline it works
better for me
make sure you have some next essential
thing that you know everyone should have
is
is gum i think people need gum
throughout the day even if it's
sugarless i think it gives you some type
of
energy and it's obviously good for your
breath
especially if you're gonna be all in
people's space i hope you have some gum
in your pocket or mint
and this is my brush one of my favorite
brushes let's keep himself
up you know i'm in the camera a lot so
this is my go-to
it's hard on one side very soft on the
other side
i actually stole it from my daughters
yeah i take care of myself
floss mouthwash soap deodorant
i put lotion on when i get out the tub
make sure you take care of yourselves
tony told you this right here
would be agua i think water is the most
essential thing
out of everything i pulled out today
it's my pre-workout
during workout purse workout it's my
dessert
wake up go to sleep water's my thing
fiji should probably call me because i
don't do this [ __ ] for nothing oh you
can't feel it
f-i-f-i-u
next thing i don't usually show people
that because everybody always asks me
what i got on i could tell you bond
number nine you can never smell like me
because it smells different on
everyone's body
not only that is it's the only cologne
that you can mix together i mean you
could take
two three or four dead fragrances and
mix it into one
so i can show you this bottle of bun
number nine so that
is my favorite fragrance of all time
i've talked about it i
rapped about it i've posted it all the
people have learned from me
and done the same thing and plagiarized
without giving me proper credit but i'm
not here for that
not a petty person
is that is that your applying techniques
i don't know it's just [ __ ] how do
you put cologne on
some dudes do the they spray and walk in
i won't
i want that [ __ ] on me i don't
understand why you would spray something
in the [ __ ] hair
no i understand why you would do that